president biden who has warned the
pandemic will get worse before it gets
better
now says the u.s death toll could top
600 thousand
on friday there were more than 186 000
new infections in the united states
but at the same time hospitalizations
are down nine percent since last week
and just over 16 million americans have
had at least
one vaccine shot this comes amid a
nationwide scramble for more covet 19
vaccine
and a new concern that the more
contagious variant of the virus
has now been detected in at least 22
states
tom hansen has more whether it's the
long lines at the tennessee dragway
turned super-sized vaccination site
or san francisco's mayor yesterday at
the opening of a site there
i'm so excited the message is the same
the vaccine is here we're not getting
the doses and the time that we need them
to distribute them
so that means we're still in this
pandemic in indiana
like too many other places shots are
given out until they run out
i wouldn't be able to sleep if i knew
that we were
wasting vaccine or disposing of
something that is so
precious right now nearly 20 million
shots have been given in the u.s
since vaccinations began in december an
average of 982
000 a day but a combination of demand
outpacing supply and too many cooks in
the distribution kitchen
has bogged down the launch of the
nation's mass inoculation process
at the current rate dr anthony fauci
estimates herd immunity
when 70 to 80 percent of americans are
vaccinated
is not just around the corner hopefully
that will be as we enter into the fall
and end the summer
health officials are also having to
balance care for covet-stricken people
and vaccination distribution
california's office of emergency
services released video friday
showing cold storage containers
available for counties
they're available to store bodies
in kentucky the governor spoke friday
about the flags outside the state
capitol commemorating more than 3 300
people
who died in that state these are all
children of god
loved by their family needed by their
community
deeply deeply missed
and the virus's variants are causing
concern
now present in 22 states including
michigan
where dr jim grant is the state chief
medical officer for blue cross blue
shield
and that means if a thousand people have
covid that means with this variant
1500 people would get this variation of
covet
now health officials are recommending
more masks
hard as it was to get people to wear one
some are saying
double up and wear at least two for cbs
this morning saturday
tom hansen new york